what happened in that motel room uh uh
it was coupon night and I was
trampolining your wife control to lm22
do you copy
Emma Swan is the only Supermax facility
in existence where there is no physical
or sexual abuse breakouts or riots this
is general population pretty impressive
yes this
he's got a gun
within the last hours there's been a
massive infraction on Supermax and this
one
it's a takeover my daughter I still on
the station
we can send him one man with one very
specific order Oh
to dream vacation I'm load up I go to
space I get inside the maximum-security
nuthouse save the president's daughter
she's not dead already
get past all the psychos have just woken
up okay I'm joking I'll do it
I can chew in the tree all eyes open
yeah City College
who sent you your old man did my dad did
he have a message for me yes
you are adopted hey you said you were
sure worried
it's perfectly safe
oh you don't have to do that a simple
thank you sir
the EMAs one is destabilized out of the
war of wood before - in fact there's an
apple my god don't talk to strangers
shoot them
[Music]
was the mystery man on his name was [ __ ]
he really yeah